- Ce
ravivent le traumatisme
de la première vague d
coronavirus qui avait ébranlé
la Chine il y a deux ans.dédédée
ses 25 millions d'habitants
qui subissent un confinement
très strict depuis deux
GUILLAUME MAROIS, prof. démogr.,
ererersité de Shanghai
- Actuellement, je suis
confiné sur le
Donc, c'est complètement
impossible de sortir du campus
les portes d'accès du campus
sont complètement barrées,rtrtr,
que ce soit pour aller
à l'épicerie ou même
pour avoir des soins.
- Guillaume Marois vit sur
l'immense campus de l'Unsisisité
de Shanghai, comme des dizaines
de milliers d'étudiantss s s s t
confinés dans leur chambre
depuis six semaines en raison
d'une éclosion sur le campus,
- Il y a une certaine anxiété
aussi au niveau de : qu'est-ce
Puisque les gens positifssososos
de quarantaine où, peut-être,
5, 10, 15 000 personnes sont
éeéeéeées dans des amphithéâtres
ou dans des arénas.
et les marchés sont fermés
depuis plus de deux semaines,
une partie de la population
craint de manquer de nourriture.
SIMON LEPLÂTRE, correspondant,
Shanghai pour "Le Monde"
beaucoup de gens qui crèvent
ààààà Shanghai en ce moment,
mais il y a beaucoup de gens
qui ont des difficulenenenenenec
ou des nouilles instantanées
tous les jours. Donc, on a vu
de jour en jour la protestation
là-dessus monter, y compcccccccc
la police ou avec des gardiens.
- Des gens ici
un marché. C'est que la moitié
des habitants de Shanghai
n'onrererererererererererererert
d'être confinés. Beaucoup ontnqe
s'organise dans les quartiers.
Certains sont sortis pour
(cris)
D'autres expriment leur colère
du balcon de leur appartement.
crient", dit l'homme qui a filmé
cette vidéo.
"Ça a commencé par quelques
personnes, maintenant tout
monde crie parce qu'on ne sait
pas ce qui se passe, personne
ne sait quand ça v
- Les autorités ne se contentent
pas de distribuer des tests
rapides. Tous les habitants
de Shanghai doivent passer
un test PCR aux deux ou trois
jours. Le Québécois Carl Breau
de dépistage de son quartier.
CARL BREAU, PDG de Saimen
- Je rencontre les voisins,
puis on jase un peu, là.
C'est la seule façon,,,,,,,,,,,,
comme savez, c'est un vrai
lockdowniririririririre qu'on
est confinés à la maison.
- L'ingénieur et homme
d'affaires, qui parle
couramment mandarin, sen
la colère des Chinois qu'il
côtoie comme bénévol
- Ce qu'on voit, dans le fond,
c'est des gens... beaucoup de
gens font des achats en ligne
a qui recoivent, il y en a
qui ne recoivent pas, il y e
a qui sont pour recevoir dans
leur quartier, finalement c'est
bloqué, la nourrit
à la porte du quartier.
les employeurs, qui doivent
faire des mises à pied massives.
Les activités manufacturières
de Carl Breau, qui fabrique
des composantes électroniques,
sont en pause.
qu'il y a rien qui s'y fabrique.
L'entrepot aussi
donc on est a l'arrêt total
depuis, ça va faire dix jours.
- Bien sûr, ça a un impact
économique très fort.
enenenenenenenenenenenenenenenes
des services; la restauration,o,
sont complètent dévastés.
♪ ♪ ♪ttttttttttttttttttttttttttt
célébré leur liberté retrouvée.
Après unsssssssssssssssssse
du nombre de cas à Shanghai
depuis plus d'un mois,
omomomomomomomomomomomomomomomo.
- Ceux qui sont libérés dansrérs
une ville fantôme parce que
tous les magasins sont fermés
et ils n'ont le droit d'aller
nulle part.SoSoSoSoSoSoSoSoSoSo,
Radio